oh god damn it I mean I was writing that
this isn't a very jump scary game but
the atmosphere is like spot-on it's
amazing Oh God all right oh [ __ ] off
Oh God go I go I go I go holy balls do
not bother him can I bother : hey MA get
out get out get out get out get out get
home to it Oh
get out of him I'm late - it was a hell
out arm Jesus get out of here one I sign
that chair for you okay the trap poof
pills hi
uh-huh what is it what is it where is it
oh I see you oh you were right up oh
you're moving look his arms moving look
he's got him animations he's not just a
static figure ah static figure yeah
nice arm so you've been doing your
tricep curls
I know tricep curls are impossible ha
I'm on the golf ah
poof very very nice uh-huh okay so we go
through here this oh I can't sprint
anymore I gotta sprint I'm not afraid
are they gonna give me ha ha get away
get away get away
ah that's all one all right saw one I
thought I saw one baby I didn't saw one
spur on run large log the boot the booty
I got it
no no this doesn't look good okay point
of no return
hmm
which way do I go oh okay that way hang
on there's more stuff here
why-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y aah this okay
balloon hi I don't know I don't know I
don't know ha ha ha her nose open now ha
ha go away
I have been blamed this has been the
random horror reaction compilation
thanks for watching if you like what you
saw and you want to see more why not
subscribe to my channel want to help the
channel grow please leave a like add it
to your favorites or share it with your
friends on Facebook and Twitter thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye